l'infirmière de 51 ans ne sera pas fixé
sur son sort aujourd'hui le jugement
était attendu au tribunal de paris ici
même à 9 heures mais en début d'audience
le tribunal a annoncé que le jugement
est prorogée au 14 juin prochain
la présidente est en souffrance ne
pouvait pas être sur place les faits
remontent au 16 juin 2020 pendant la
manifestation des personnels soignants
en pleine crise du coronavirus pour
demander au gouvernement plus de moyens
et plus de considération de leur
quotidien une infirmière dans un geste
de désespoir lance un pavé sur la police
sera arrêtée et mise en garde à vue elle
expliquera au tribunal que c'est ce jet
de pavé est un geste symbolique contre
l'état pas d'intention de faire de mal
elle déclara même que ses mains
d'infirmières sont faites pour soigner
et non pas pour faire du mal elle
reconnaît ce jet de pierres mais ne
reconnaît pas avoir insulté les
policiers chose que retiendra bien sûr
le procureur de la république qui l'a
relaxera concernant ces insultes au
tribunal c'est la partie civile était
présente une dizaine de policiers dans
les couloirs l'infirmière sera fixé sur
son sort le 14 juin prochain elle risque
jusqu'à deux mois de prison avec sursis